aber weiter bis luca meine lieben
zuschauer ich habe bereits vor einem
jahr ein video gemacht mit jule und
sarah 13 9 juli in dem video ging es
darum dass ich von gerade ein video
aufzunehmen jetzt gibt dir aus und fängt
tauben ehre auf jeden fall ging es dir
hier was ich vor einem jahr mit juroren
sache gemacht habe darum dass ich einige
fragen darauf geschrieben habe und
schauen wollte wer mich besser kennt
heute kommt er sozusagen zweite teil
davon mehr oder weniger allerdings
diesmal nicht gegen meine schwester an
sondern gegen carola meine beste
freundin mehr oder weniger auf jeden
fall kenne ich carola bereits seit fünf
jahren allerdings ist auf der anderen
seite jule obwohl ich seit eineinhalb
jahren kenner halt meine freundin und
verbringt am meisten zeit mit mir
deswegen ist heute auch sehr spannend
sagen wir direkt mit der ersten frage
und zwar adidas oder nike juli heißt ist
bestimmt als wenn du es nicht weiß ich
mag beide marken auf jeden fall also ich
falle das was alters rausbringen und ich
fange das was nicht raus bringt
allerdings ist es ja nun eine
entscheidungsfrage also was man ich
lieber adidas oder nike eure antworten
321 ich hätte gedacht gesagt beide
safeline war richtig aber nur weil ja
aber deswegen fahre ich nein gerade die
nächste frage ist eigentlich ziemlich
gysi glaube ich ich frage mich ob carola
das war es was ist mein geburtsdatum
da muss ich jetzt glaube ich nicht viel
zu sagen also was ist mein geburtstag
eure antworten bitte im 32
die dritte frage des seit welchem jahr
bin ich ein richtiger erster fc köln
fällt also ich wohne ja schon ein paar
jahre in köln bin aber so richtig fc-fan
erst geworden in welchem
321 1818 ist das geld richtig sagen so
richtig 2018 als das kopf-an-kopf-rennen
die nächste frage könnten glaube ich
auch beide ziemlich easy beantworten und
zwar was ist mein lieblings alkohol
mischgetränk also ich meine jetzt nicht
irgendwie das getränk was ich da mit dem
alkoholische oder ich meine auch nicht
denn alkohol an sich sondern ich meine
beispielsweise wodka red bull so wodka
energy so platte antworten bitte in 321
titanic richtig ok beiden anderen punkt
die fünfte frage ist wieder eine
entscheidungsfrage eine entweder oder
frage und zwar sommer oder winter könnt
ihr glaube ich relativ easy und schnell
beantworten eure antworten 32
das ist richtig also das ist ja dass die
schwierige fragen kommen noch wann war
ich das erste mal beim tumor elend was
soll ich das denn ich glaube ich muss
nachdenken eure antworten bitte in 32 15
15 und du sagst 2015 2014 wurde ich 18
liegt nahe aus wie viele buchstaben
besteht meine zweite dame der wenig dass
jemand seine absätze zeiten haben eure
antwort bitte in 32 14
ich sag dir sagt vielleicht mit harvey
die in stilles wasser oder mit
kohlensäure was kommt das fressen weil
ich eure antwort wird in 3 21
[Musik]
ja ich dachte immer gehören über viel
besser bestellt und dann haben wir
einfach stimmt es dass er dazu bestellt
dann hat die kleinen städte betroffen
sind alle mächtig habe das stück der
punkt ein jude was ist mein lieblingsort
das war's hier wirklich komplett es gibt
jetzt ziemlich viele verschiedene kölsch
braut schluss dass mit dem bag auf 5 es
gibt auf jeden fall ziemlich
verschiedene käsesorten und auch
innerhalb einer kölsch sollte wenn man
beispielsweise gab es dann auch wieder
verschiedene arten davon
es ist auch nicht gesagt einfach eure
antwort in 32 14
mühlen kölsch sagt julia und du sagst
dass raisdorf hättest und mühlen kölsch
ist auch länger aber herr lieblings das
war mein bachelor schnitt
das nehme ich das überhaupt mit euch
auch wenn du mir auf jeden fall noch
mehr mühe geben können bei meinem
bachelor vor allem auch bei der bachelor
arbeit aber es geht ja um den gesamten
schnitt meines gesamten studiums und
nicht nur die bachelorarbeit von da her
eure antwort wissen 321 sorry du hast es
ja fast jede frage gerichtsbeamten das
ist jetzt fragen sie denke ich nur jude
richtig exakt beantworten könnte und
zwar wie viel wiege ich wie viel kilo
gesamt pure muskelmasse habe ich am
körper als mal eure antworten auf diese
frage bitte in 32 14 79 oder 80 79 84
völlig gerne wiegen habe ich sogar mal
ein paar wochen stand nach 84 drauf nach
nun kommt mit einer ziemlich komische
frage allerdings vielleicht aufgrund der
jetzigen situation bei mir ganz lustig
und zwar vor wie vielen tagen weil ich
das letzte mal beim friseur
die sache ist es ja schon lang länger
wachsen lasse aber zwischendurch mal so
ein bisschen frei geschnitten
eure antworten auf die frage vor wie
viel tagen war ich das letzte mal beim
friseur bitte in 3 21 21 und 22 sind 63
bei der nächsten frage gibt es viele
verschiedene antworten und zwar nenne
einen meiner lieblings dj da kann man
eigentlich nicht so viel falsch oder gar
keine namen von den ganzen ja immer ja
nett mir bitte einen bei der lieblings
djs in 321 martin war das richtig ich
habe drei djs aufgeschrieben das war ein
fischer max martin garrigues aber bei
eure antworten sind richtig
dementsprechend kommt ihr beide 1 punkt
sehr gut gemacht wo haben carola und ich
uns kennengelernt
was weißt du auch ja okay gut
dementsprechend eure antworten bisschen
3 2 1 2
nun gewinnt auch wieder die person die
am nächsten an dem datum dran ist und
zwar an welchem tag bin ich nach köln
gezogen jetzt kann ich heute nicht
sprechen
[Musik]
die sollten wir witzig das genaue datum
nennen also beispielsweise erster januar
1958 eure antwort bitte in 32 ein erster
3014 fünfzehnter september 2015 julius
näher dran ist direkt ist ja das heißt
direkt ist war mitte 2014 ich glaube 15
august 2014 oder so aber julia hat auf
jeden fall den punkt was war mein erstes
auto bitte die genaue bezeichnung das
genaue modell eure antwort bitte im 3
21 junge hewlett war genau richtig hanks
mini cooper s cabrio kommen wir nun zur
von den 20 fragen dich vorbereitet habe
und zwar nenne meine zwei lieblings
hunderassen
ich denke bei einer runde rasse wird sie
bei der direct bescheid aber bei der
zweiten
also meine absolute lieblingsstadt rasse
kennt ja glaube ich beide die ist glaube
ich auch aber bei der zweiten runde
raste das ist halt das vielleicht
schwersten idee aber das ist auch schon
wieder zurück sagt immer was man ist
sich hübsch stück nicht eure antworten
bitte in 321 und gehört über nicht so
richtig glauben können interessierte
behilflich ist 20 jahre her aber ich bin
auch gespannt ob ich jetzt sage okay
viola hast du aber mittlerweile aber
sehr gut nur hätte ich glaube ich auch
noch den punkt gegeben nun wieder eine
datums schätzfrage und zwar an welchem
tag habe ich meinen youtube-kanal
erstellt wie kann ich auf jeden fall
einen kleinen tipp geben sag ich mal und
zwar habe ich jetzt schon angefangen mit
videos als noch zu hause gewohnt habe
und ihr wisst ja jetzt wann ich nach
köln gezogen bin das bayer-mittel 2014
euer geschätztes datum für diese
vorletzte frage bitte eben 3 2 1
was hast du gesagt verwechselt und
dritter 6
und dann das august 2011 alter da sieht
man dass carola wirklichen langjähriger
fan ist
die letzte frage meine sehr verehrten
zuschauer und zwar mit wieviel jahren
wurden mir die weisheitszähne entfernt
also wie alt war ich bei der op tabak
ein video darüber wie man vielmehr die
weisheitszähne entfernt wurden um das
könnte sonst hätte ich mich auch
gefilmter irgendwie ja gibt es ja nicht
wo du so eine scheiße labert wenn wir
eure antwort wie alt ich war als mir die
weisheitszähne raus genommen wurden
bitte im 3 22 du sagst 18 und 20 jahren
hat sich rein und hinten ein dass ich
mir zurück 21 das heißt der punkt geht
an julia gesagt dass auch meine lieben
freunde hier seht ja schon die ganze
zeit um den punktestand eingeblendet und
sieht jetzt auch schon der gewonnen hat
wir wissen das allerdings nicht denn
anni familie hat sich die punkte auf
jeden fall während des videos notiert
wir wissen noch nicht wer wie viele
punkte hatte ich glaube es ist sehr eng
pany wie viele punkte hat jule 14 punkte
bei 20 fragen ist auf jeden fall sehr
gut wie viele punkte hat carola ich
hätte dich gedacht ich hätte ich gedacht
jetzt mehr als jetzt denn jetzt alter
glückwunsch jule cluster das sehr gut
gemacht stellte mich das heutige video
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben freunde
wenn es euch gefallen dann auch
eventuell auch einen dritten teil haben
wollt vielleicht auch ein bisschen er
als erster wieder in einem jahr oder
eine eventuelle carola gegen sarah
antritt oder vielleicht meine mutter
gegen jule oder so dann schnappen und in
die kommentare gast einen daumen hoch da
werde ich das video gefallen hat und
jetzt mal ein kanal falls sie noch nicht
teil der lupus
[Musik]